what emails have you what have you seen
in the top
of an email above the fold for a sas
company
that makes you say you know to
you know the great laney or uh you know
whoever on your team uh
get them you know billy whoever just get
on it
what do you see on the top half of the
email um
it's uh typically we want to see
i i'd say like month of a month growth
rate is a pretty important thing to see
god i mean that would definitely get our
attention you know if you're growing
you know anything above 10 is good but
certainly in the 15 to 20
month over month that's going to get our
attention uh as you're
you know get closer to that million
dollar ar milestone
um you know that certainly would get our
attention
got it so if you if the email said
uh we you know
17 average month over month growth last
three months
uh mr sachs i saw you on jason's podcast
um
we built sas software for blank yes and
uh we are 62 of the way on our current
run rate to hitting your million dollars
would love to uh take a deeper dive into
it even a short email like that's going
to make you click on the link
shorter is better i mean all you really
have to say well because all
because all i really need to know is
that you believe you're the early
category leader
in you know x sas business software
and that you're kind of getting close to
what we call a series a milestone which
would be
you know a million dollars or hundreds
of thousands of dollars of arr
and that you're growing at that
month-over-month growth rate that's all
i need to know in the email to know that
we should take a look at it and then
you know the team's gonna so there's no
or someone on the team to look at it
there's no reason for me to write three
paragraphs about my last two failed
startups
i mean it is the email we get right i
mean and it's amazing how founders work
against their own best interest though
even the ones who have
the goods will write three or four
paragraphs of their life story
and it's tldr it's too long
you know and they've they people forget
how many emails we get
yeah or you know the first couple of
paragraphs will be talking about how
much they love my blog on xyz which you
know i'm happy about but that doesn't
you know it's it it doesn't matter
right it's not one sentence okay read
your blog post about x it resonated with
me
right then let's get to brass tacks
right
and the timing in which you in you
contact an investor is so important i
mean
i don't know how many emails do you get
with people saying i have an idea
or i'm building a product and they just
haven't launched it yet
yeah i mean i get i get a zillion of
these emails but i get very very few
that are in the format that i mentioned
and um
it's such an unlock yeah it's so well
it's an unlock if you actually have
those metrics
i mean i i wonder if the reason i don't
get those emails because most companies
most artists don't have those metrics it
is hard i mean i
we've been very intentional about
telling people hey if you have 10
5 10 customers and 5 to 10k in revenue
even as little as 2k
we'll talk to you about the accelerator
um and that's really helped us with the
true north and i think you just saying
explicitly
hey when you're trending towards a
million and if you're over 10 but
you know more in the 15 that's good you
know if you just keep putting it out
there it does work